-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Casey Wilson
We're talking about
her fantastic new book.
And, Casey, I always find it's
very nice when people
who have been successful
in show business
share stories about how
it wasn't necessarily the case
for their entire career.
You write about an agent
showcase that you were not
particularly well,
I guess, prepared for?
How would you describe it?
-I was well-prepared,
but I made some wrong choices.
So, an agent showcase is
when agents come,
and you have like
40 seconds to do
a monologue or
a scene and impress them
for them to try to find you.
And I picked a poignant scen
where I was being kidnappe
and I wore a paper bag
over my head
the duration of the scene.
And I just
pulled it off at the end,
and the lights went off.
And I was like,
"My acting will be so stirring
and so good and my beauty
will -- my 40-year-old beaut
at any age will shine
through that paper bag,
and you'll want to sign me
I was not signed by
anyone, Seth.
-But you do still have,
on your head shots,
"special skills -- bag acting.
-I'm great at it.
I can do plastic, brown bag --
-You can do all the bags.
That's what everybody always
says about you.
-Canvas Lands' End bag.
I'll do anything you need, yeah.
-I want to also
talk about some sad news.
You recently lost a pet.
Can you tell us about
your dearly departed?
-It's hard to talk about, Seth
But people are going to thin
I'm doing a bit and I'm joking
and I'm not.
I had a beta fish
named Spongy that
I was the only one
that took care of.
My kids did nothing.
And I would, like, sit by th
tank and look into his eyes.
They come when you
come in to feed them.
There is a connection, Seth,
between people
and their beta fish.
And I loved this fish,
but, unfortunately,
I murdered him
when I put in some grass
that I bought from Amazon,
thinking he
could have,
like, a little hideaway.
And it was so sharp,
unfortunately,
it speared Spongy.
-Wait. The thing
you bought to make it
a nicer locale for him
fully killed it?
-That's right. Unfortunately
And, so, I -- This is a
public service announcement.
Honestly, I'm mad at Amazon.
Never took the time to learn
the actual company
that I bought the grass from
But I just want people
to be careful.
Like, you can
love something to death.
Because it was really
upsetting to see him speared
but a lot of people
have reached out to me
that they love
their beta fish, too.
One woman cremated hers, okay?
Another woman
tried mouth-to-mouth.
People are connected
to beta fish,
and I just don't feel
it's talked about enough.
-Did you own up
to your family that you were -
that you had brought about
the demise of the fish?
-No. I was like,
"Oh, no, Spongy --
something happened to him.
You know what?
There are terrible people
in my family.
Not one of them even,
like, registered Spongy's death.
I was hysterically crying
to my husband,
and he was, like, typing.
He was like, "Mm-hmm."
They're monsters.
Monsters, all of them.
-You do have a nice relationship
with your husband,
both personally
and professionally,
because he created
"Black Monday."
Third season of the show.
Congratulations.
Is it nice to
work with your spouse?
-It is nice.
It has some strange elements
I'm in "Black Monday"
on Showtime,
and so it's a bit racier.
He will --
I guess I'm 100 years old.
But he wrote a sex scene
for me in which --
And may I
speak freely here, Seth?
-Please, please.
-Okay.
-I'm, again,
a 40-year-old woman and a mom.
You don't expect
to get these sex scenes
where you're being,
essentially --
and I'm sorry
to speak so freely --
but taken from behind by a man
My husband is
at the monitor like,
"Little to the left,
a little to the right."
Doesn't care at all.
And the gentleman playing
my paramour was
Britney Spears' boyfriend,
so a lot was going on,
a lot of elements.
-Yeah.
-But he's
a wonderful actor, Sam.
So, there was a lot
going on at play.
But my husband could give --
He doesn't care
What's happening
with me out there, and...
So he's throwing me
out there to the wolves.
-I think that speaks to
the nice balance
you have in your relationship.
-It's work-life balance.
It's beautiful, really.
-Hey, congratulations
so much on the book.
It is always so nice
to see you, Casey.
-Thank you so much, Seth,
for having me.
I love seeing you. Thank you